SPERO:ING.
AT THE OTHER IS A
CHARM.
LET'S SEE IT. DOING SOME DAMAGE
HERE IN THE THIRD PERIOD.ED
SAVED BY MILES BRIDGES WITH THE
>> NO ANKLES WERE BROKEN IN THE.
AND
THIRD QUARTER.
THE LEAD, 13 FOR ON THE OTHER
END.
>> Richard: JEEZ.
>> Ian: PORTIS WITH AN OPEN FE
GIVES THE NETS A TWO-POINT
CAREER.an: THE
>> M. Jones: WHAT?
GOING.
LIKE THEY'RE PLAYING THROUGH
HE MAKES IT LOOK SO EASY.
ELEVATION
LETS IT FLY FOR THREE.
GOT IT.  CAPSID AWAY
INSTINCTS.
YOU EITHER HAVE IT OR YOYO A BL.
HIS SECOND TONIGHT.UL
REALLY EASY FOR NIKOLA JOKIC.
ANYM
SHOOTING THREES, WH.INCREDIBLY
PORTER JR. HIS LIFE.
SEEMINGLY HAD  THE WIN --
OH, IT IS GOOD!
OFOF
>> Pete: OF THE
SQUARE. THE BOX ON THE BACK OR
LOOK AHE
SWITCH.
HE WENT TO SWITCH.
AND DOWN THE LANE!
STEVENS